Why is the Iron Throne suddenly being so violent?
Does this chair have a mind of its own or
is Viserys just accident-prone?
Stay tuned to find out.
King Viserys Targaryen is a pretty clumsy
guy, isn't he?
Sure, he's a mighty ruler, the patriarch of
Westeros' finest family, and a builder of
scale models.
However, the guy can't seem to sit on the
Iron Throne without inflicting serious and
wildly infectious cuts on himself — which
seems like a pretty strange character flaw,
considering that the seat is a very central
part of his job.
After all, pretty much everyone who sat on
the Iron Throne in Game of Thrones could lounge
on it any way they wanted without filleting
their muscles or appendages.
As the people who are familiar with George
R.R.
Martin's source material may already suspect,
there's a reason behind this dramatic change
in the Iron Chair's effects on the person
who sits on it, and the reason goes far beyond
Viserys Targaryen's personal sitting skills.
In Game of Thrones, the dangers associated
with the Iron Throne tend to stem from the
fact that if you sit on it, several factions
will attempt to remove you from it by any
means necessary.
However, George R.R.
Martin's A Song of Ice and Fire series depicts
a very different Iron Throne.
The throne was designed by none other than
Aegon I Targaryen, aka the Conqueror.
Being a tough enough guy to earn a nickname
like "The Conqueror" in this universe, Aegon
wanted to make sure that whatever rulers came
after him would be up to the task.
The Iron Throne was created as a combination
of a stealth test and a method for weeding
out the unworthy.
It's uncomfortable, sharp, and dangerous,
so if you're not as vigilant as a ruler should
be, it's very quick to remind you in the shape
of a cut or maybe five.
Because of the Throne's tendency to cut the
ruler who doesn't have their head screwed
on right, Martin's lore includes mentions
of several kings who didn't respect the throne.
The most notorious one would probably be one
Maegor Targaryen, who was so bad at sitting
that the Iron Throne actually killed him.
Another name worth mentioning is "The Mad
King" Aerys II, who was eventually killed
by Jaime Lannister only after he had injured
himself by slouching on the throne.
Even the reigning awful king, Joffrey Baratheon,
cuts himself in the books.
It definitely appears that Viserys Targaryen
isn't the kind of guy the throne approves, either.
Episode 1 of House of the Dragon includes
what seems to be an example of correct Iron
Throne posture.
When Viserys banishes Daemon near the end
of Episode 1, he's sitting straight as an
arrow, wielding a sword of his own.
Daemon walks away, and Viserys immediately
cuts his finger on the throne.
Add that to the back injury he sustained before
the beginning of the series, and it's not
hard to suspect that the character might not
see the end of the show.
The dangerous nature of the Iron Throne is
reflected in its design.
It's difficult for a large seat made of swords
to be unassuming, but that's exactly what
the original show version is compared to the
new House of the Dragon Iron Throne.
"There aren't a thousand blades.
There aren't even two hundred.
I've counted."
This pointy, jutty thing surrounded by scores
of blades is not the kind of thing you'd imagine
hauling on the convention circuit for fans
to take selfies in unless they're very, very
careful fans.
After all, the House of the Dragon Iron Throne
is even dangerous on set, because there are
real weapons incorporated in its design.
Still, while closer to Martin's vision than
the original, even the new seat is a far cry
from the Iron Throne of the books.
The book version is an asymmetrical, dragon-sized
mountain of bent and tormented blades.
The House of the Dragon version still isn't
quite there, but its bulky, dangerous-looking
design makes it clear that this is very different
from the beloved original.
Perhaps someone in the show eventually becomes
tired of cutting themselves whenever they
sit down on what's effectively their office
chair, and commissions the relatively streamlined
and more efficient version we see on Game
of Thrones.